Before there was a city here, there was only this.
Forest, ice, and a river that froze solid for half of every year.
Nothing about this place promised greatness.
The nearest thing to a road was the river itself.
And here is the other thing you need to know before we begin.
Moscow burns.
Again and again across eight centuries, this city has been burned to the ground.
And every single time, it grew back.
That is the real story.
Not conquest, not glory.
Survival, and the stubborn habit of rebuilding on ash.
In the twelfth century, this was the edge of the known Russian world.
Dense forest, frozen marsh, and trading paths.
A borderland that mattered to almost nobody.
Kyiv was the centre of Russian life then, and Kyiv was far to the south.
In eleven forty seven, a prince named Yuri Dolgoruky called a meeting at a small wooden outpost on a hill above the Moskva river.
That single line is the first time Moscow appears in writing.
He was inviting an ally to dinner.
The chronicle records the meal, not a founding.
He did not found a capital.
He fortified a waypoint.
A timber wall, a few hundred people, and a good position between two rivers.
That was all Moscow was.
Its value was traffic, not power.
And a wooden town in open forest has one defining weakness.
It cannot survive fire, and it cannot survive cavalry.
Within a century it would face both at once.
In twelve thirty seven, riders came out of the east carrying news nobody wanted to believe.
Something enormous was moving across the steppe, and it was moving toward them.
They had perhaps a year of warning, and it made no difference at all.
The Mongols under Batu Khan did not raid.
They erased.
Russian city after Russian city fell in weeks, and the armies sent to stop them simply ceased to exist.
Riazan refused to surrender and was annihilated.
Vladimir, seat of the grand prince, fell in three days.
Moscow's turn came in the winter of twelve thirty eight.
The walls were wood.
The defenders were few.
The town was taken and burned in a matter of days.
It was not considered important enough to be remembered as a great siege.
What remained was ash on frozen ground.
For any ordinary settlement that is the end of the record.
A name in a chronicle, and nothing written after it.
But people came back to the hill.
They rebuilt in timber, knowing it would burn again, because the position was worth the risk.
That decision made everything that followed possible.
Timber was cheap, and the rivers still met here.
For the next two hundred years, Russia lived under the Golden Horde.
Princes did not rule.
They paid, they knelt, and they waited.
The Horde issued a document called the yarlyk, and whichever prince held it ruled on the Khan's behalf.
And this is where Moscow does something genuinely unexpected.
It did not rise by fighting the Mongols.
It rose by working for them.
Ivan the first earned a nickname that tells you everything.
Kalita.
Moneybag.
He persuaded the Horde to let Moscow collect the tribute owed by every other Russian principality.
It was a tax farm, and Moscow was running it.
Every year the silver passed through Moscow's hands on its way east.
And every year a portion of it did not continue the journey.
The city grew rich on the arrangement.
The city bought land, absorbed its neighbours, and paid for churches.
Within two generations it was the strongest principality in the north.
By thirteen eighty, Moscow was strong enough to stop paying.
Prince Dmitry met the Horde's army at Kulikovo, on open ground, and won.
The Horde had fractured into rival factions, and Dmitry judged the moment correctly.
It was the first time a Russian army had beaten the Mongols in the field.
A psychological wall broke that day.
But be careful with this victory.
He took the name Donskoy from the river he fought beside.
Two years later the Horde came back and burned Moscow again.
Real independence took another full century, and when it came, it came under Ivan the third.